is cinco de mayo you remember
celebrations they were virtual last year
because of the pandemic
so restaurants are gearing up all day
for fiestas and hector is already geared
up as you can see he is live this
morning over at el dorado cantina in
tivoli village
hector good morning to you what's on tap
hey there good morning you know i'm
loving this so much i wish i could wear
it every single day it's actually my
second time this week wearing it and
why not get festive right and we can
also get festive with the food
joining us live we have chef john
miranda to talk to us not just about the
food but a lot of people wondering about
drink specials good morning good morning
yeah so today we have
a 20 picture of model especially we also
have
our classic margarita for five dollars
if you want to shoot yourself we have
other versions that quickly pair and so
forth and they're made with casa lotus
a margarita for just five bucks five
dollars
all right show me the tacos let's talk
about the tacos sure so we have a pulled
chicken taco we have a
rajas for the vegetarians and then we
have carnitas and asada
all right so the food looks delicious it
tastes delicious
what sort of drives the passion behind
all of the dishes here
you know we take a lot of pride in
sourcing her sourcing our food and
uh and what goes into to serving the
guests right
um it's a it's definitely you know we
are like for example chicken is organic
non-gmo
you know our pork comes from a farm
called salmon creek
and uh you know the steroid free
antibiotic-free
and uh from a business perspective you
know a lot of places across town
finally looking forward to hosting
people all over again this time last
year
restaurants were doing only curbside
pick up and out they can walk inside
feel the cinco de mayo vibe all over
again
tell us you know as you guys get ready
for this big day for business
um what's the vibe going to be like here
today
festive to say the least yeah we we
we expect you know a full house from you
know
from you know lunch until we phones are
ringing
it's now it is uh you know we're very
happy to have a full house again because
people are having a good time with their
families and getting back to seeing
us again it's great to hear thank you
for having us early in the morning so
they're actually open 24 7 so these guys
pulled
basically an all-nighter so there you go
these are some of the festivities
happening here in town in las vegas for
cinco de mayo for now reporting live
hector mejia
8 news now back to you guys